los angeles is best known as
the center of hollywood film and tv
production but it's also home to the
largest container ports in north america
every year this facility handles more
than nine million
individual cargo containers and
processes more than 276 billion dollars
worth of goods flowing in and out
of the ports it's the single biggest
entry port
for goods from asia cars clothes
electronics
everything that americans buy probably
passes through these ports
with all of that activity it takes a
huge
number of vehicles to keep cargo flowing
a big problem with all those vehicles
though is emissions
particulate matter from diesel exhaust
and
nearly 900 000 tons
of carbon dioxide every year
the state of california has said that
over the next two decades
it wants to eliminate sales of all new
gasoline and diesel-powered vehicles
in the state and not just passenger cars
but heavy-duty trucks
buses basically everything that moves on
on wheels
you might not know it but this is a real
hot spot for advanced technology
vehicles
well first of all air quality has been a
challenge
in the southern california area overall
for a long time every time
we look on the internet and hear
something on the radio
or the television we're hearing about
dramatic
weather events that are occurring
somewhere in the world
the largest this the most significant
that
the most serious this uh the worst that
and all of it can be attributed and
traced to
changes in climate and so
we have to do our part to reduce
the impact of greenhouse gas
on our atmosphere and on
our climate so there's already a huge
number of battery-powered vehicles
operating down here at the ports
but something very unique is also
running around here
starting about two years ago toyota
which has its own
massive container facility bringing in
lots of cars coming in from japan
started operating a couple of hydrogen
fuel cell semi trucks
these are vehicles that are completely
electric but instead of being powered by
batteries their electricity is coming
through a process in which
the hydrogen makes your electricity to
power the vehicle
batteries charge up and carry the power
hydrogen fuel cells make it on demand
we're realizing that the technology is
um is
capable and and compatible with the duty
cycle and that we are
getting good results from our prototypes
so i think um our next step is really to
figure out now how to
turn this uh turn this into something uh
you know bigger than just a handful of
prototypes and feasibility trucks you
know we're certainly looking at
what our options are for that now toyota
right now
is running two modified kenworth class
eight semi trucks
back and forth from its port facility
but by the end of this year
we'll have five to six more and a dozen
in 2021.
they're hauling around 80 000 pounds is
not an easy task and it's really
a tough thing to do with batteries um
only
and that's because you know the
batteries have a huge mass
that you have to contend with and uh of
course the laws of physics are such that
recharging times are also quite
significant
and you know what we've learned in these
last six years of doing this project is
that
uh you know people who are operating
trucks uh as their business
uh are very very sensitive to the time
and very very sensitive to total cost of
ownership
and so when trucks sitting around not
operating that's money that they're not
earning
so it's really important to give them
something that looks and actually feels
like diesel which we think hydrogen does
the ports have been trying to clean up
their emissions for many many years
because the air quality problems down
here
have been a serious issue since the
1970s and 80s but things are really
picking up pace now
they're already putting lots of new
battery powered and hydrogen vehicles
on the docks to haul cargo but that's
likely to get a big push
over the next 10 to 15 years because the
state of california
wants to basically make it illegal by
to sell brand new gasoline or
diesel-powered cars
california is going to 100 percent zero
emission vehicles
and that's not just passenger cars that
means these big trucks back here
hauling these multi-ton cargo containers
off of ships
to warehouses and and factories and
stores near where you live
but it's all starting here at the ports
right now and it's only going to get
bigger year by year
you